♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
WRAPPER KANYE WEST HAS SPENT
FOUR DAYS POSTING PRO TRUMP
CONTENT ON TWITTER.
FIRST, BRET BAIER JUST HAD A
DEEPLY REVEALING INTERVIEW WITH
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JIM COMEY.
DURING THAT INTERVIEW, COMEY
SAID THAT IT WAS NOT CENTRAL TO
THEIR QUEST FOR A FISA WARRANT
WITH PEOPLE AFFILIATED WITH THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
SPEAK WHAT YOU CALLED THE
DOSSIER UNVERIFIED, SALACIOUS.
WHY WOULD YOU USE THAT FOR
CARTER PAGE?
YOU LEAD WITH IT.
WHY?
>> THAT'S NOT MY RECOLLECTION.
I DON'T KNOW THE FISA
APPLICATION -- IT WAS PART OF A
BROADER FACT THAT WAS LAID
BEFORE THE JUDGE.
>> THERE WAS MORE THAN THE
DOSSIER?
>> MY RECOLLECTION IS THAT THERE
WAS A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT ABOUT
THE PAGE AND THERE IS PROBABLE
CAUSE TO BELIEVE THAT HE WAS
PART OF IT.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW IT'S
HIDING BEHIND GOVERNMENT SECRECY
AGAIN.
TREY GOWDY REPRESENTS
SOUTH CAROLINA.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
MR. CHAIRMAN, THANKS FOR COMING
ON.
WHAT DID YOU LEARN FROM IT?
>> A COUPLE OF THINGS.
PAGE AND STRZOK HE WOULD HAVE
FIRED IMMEDIATELY.
THOSE INVESTIGATIONS SHOULD HAVE
BEEN CANNED.
DIRECTOR COMEY'S RECOLLECTION IS
FLAWED.
HE NEEDS TO GET HIS ORDERS TO GO
BACK AND LOOK AT THE TRANSCRIPT.
WE DID NOT MISS HERE, MAYBE HE
MISSPOKE, BUT THAT'S IN THE
TRANSCRIPT.
THE DOUBLE STANDARD THAT HE'S
HAD FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS
STILL EXIST.
IF TRUMP TELLS ANY LIES AT ALL,
IT'S A REMEDY FOR HIM.
>> Tucker: MARTHA STEWART WENT
TO PRISON FOR LYING.
HE DOESN'T REMEMBER WHEN HE
FIRST HEARD ABOUT THE STEEL
DOSSIER, IS THAT POSSIBLE?
>> IF HE LEARNED ABOUT IT IN THE
FALL OF 2016, IT WAS ALREADY
KNOWN THAT THE DEMOCRATS HAD
BEEN TIPPED OFF ON THAT.
WHOEVER BRIEFED HIM, WHY WOULD
YOU JUST SAY IT INCLUDES THE
DEMOCRATS FINISHING IT?
THE PART OF IT NOT BEING PART OF
THE FISA APPLICATION, WHY DID
YOU USE IT AT ALL?
IT WAS JUST WRONG.
IT WAS AN INDISPENSABLE PART OF
THE APPLICATION PERIOD.
>> Tucker: HOW CAN HE CLAIM
OTHERWISE?
HIS FIRST REACTION IS YOU CAN'T
PROVE ME WRONG BECAUSE YOU AND
THE REST OF CIVILIANS ARE ASKING
THESE QUESTIONS AND YOU DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO THE RELEVANT
INFORMATION.
YOU DO, YOU'VE SEEN IT.
THAT FORMS A CENTRAL PART OF THE
REQUEST.
CORRECT?
>> THERE ARE THREE PARTS OF IT.
THIS IS ONE OF THE PARTS.
THEY LEAD WITH IT AND IT
OCCUPIED A DISPROPORTIONATELY
LARGE PART OF THAT.
I GO BACK AND ASK IF IT WASN'T
IMPORTANT, THEN WHY DID YOU USE
IT?
WHY DID YOU USE IT AND WHY DID
YOU LEAD WITH IT?
>> Tucker: LETS A STRIP AWAY
THE POLITICS SO WE CAN SEE
CLEARLY.
AT THE CORE IS THE ALLEGATION OF
CARTER PAGE, THE HAPLESS CARTER
PAGE WAS ACTING AS THE FORMER
DIRECTOR SAID TONIGHT, THE AGENT
OF A FOREIGN POWER.